g avant de recevoir Julie j'aimerais
qu'on ait une version alors Sébastien
cohet il a agi sur le front judiciaire
avant la plainte de Julie puisqu'il a dé
pososé la semaine dernière une plainte
pour harcèlement et cyber harcèlement ça
c'est la première chose ensuite julie a
déposé plainte une enquête préliminaire
on va le rappeler est ouverte pour viol
sur mineur de plus de 15 ans et viol et
Sébastien cohet contre-attaque dépose
plainte en dénonciation calomnieuse son
entourage et lui sont clairs il n'a pas
commis les faits pour lequel pour
lesquels la plainte a été déposée il n'a
rien fait pour lui il n'y a pas eu de
viol il crie à la machination au complot
et il estime que c'est une
déstabilisation voilà donc il ni
purement et simplement les faits voilà
la défense de Sébastien cet Julie va
être avec nous dans quelques secondes
puisqu'on va faire un petit reccap et
elle est avec nous juste après à 20h55
c'est
parti depuis un mois l'animateur C fait
couler beaucoup d'encre et fait l'objet
de lourdes accusations des SMS m
extrêmement salass sont dévoilé qu'
aurait fait à une jeune femme qui à
l'époque était mineure pour rappel
l'homme k n l' fait reprocher est
aujourd'hui visé par une enquête pour
viol sur mineur de plus de 15 ans et
viol et a été écarté de l'antenne de
Energie Energie a jugé que c'était très
compliqué que Sébastien cet reste à
l'antenne une enquête ouverte après la
plainte de Julie une jeune femme de 25
ans tu es malsin mais tu n'es pas
auudessus des lois tu savais que nous
étions mineurs Julie victime présumée de
Cé témoig ce soir dans
BMP Julie merci d'être avec nous ce soir
en direct c'est le premier plateau en
direct que vous faites en télévision
Julie
déjà pourétendre un peu c'est vrai que
j' je savais même pas que tu avais
participé à un clip avec nous avec toute
l'équipe si me rappelle à l'époque
c'était pour la Coupe du monde je crois
c'est ça c'est ça en 2018 si je dis pas
de bêtises ouais bon cétait on avait
bien rigolé c'était c'était pas mal
ouais c'était bien bah merci en tout cas
alors je sais que tu avais mis un mot
sur les réseaux ouais nous remercier en
tout cas l'équipe tu aimes bien la tu
aimes bien la télé tu aimes bien la
radio c'est c'est un univers que tu ça
c'est c'est ma passion c'est enfin
c'était ma passion quiement c'est plus
ta passion maintenant par rapport à tout
ce qui s'est passé c'est plus ma passion
non mais tu tu étais fan de plein
d'animateurs ou tu es tu es vraiment
becoup plus Sébastien cé voilà ou
j'étais fan de plusieurs animateurs
parce que tu vois j'étais j'étais venu
te voir à europin il y avait Valérie
Benaï alors tu peux l' tu peux l'appeler
comme tu veux he oui il y avait Valérie
et j'aimais bien sur europin ce qu'elle
faisait donc et moi moi non moi non mais
je dis pas que rigole je rigole je
rigole pour te détendre un peuis c'est
compliqué pour toi j'étais venu j'étais
venu sur eurin tuaimais bien moi
tuaimais bien Valérie tuaimais bien cé
j'avais été à enfin je sais pas si j'ai
le droit de citer attention si
t'inquiète mais j'avais été à P radio
j'avais été à Energie j'avais été à
europin vousouvoir ouais et j'avais été
voir celou enfin j'avais fait plein
d'émissions c'est ta passion quoi c'est
vraiment c'est c'était vraiment ce que
je voulais faire ouais tu kiffais être
dans le public et tout j'adorais ben
c'est pas que je kiffais être dans le
public c'est ce que je je kiffais en
fait regarder comment travailler comment
vous travaillez et prendre les conseils
tu vois alors moi comme je travaille pas
tu as dû rien voir mais les autres oui
mais si tu travailles tout le monde
travaille Valérie JEI moi j'admirais
Valérie et et ses interventions et je me
suis dit en fait tu avais envie d'être
un peu comme Valérie ouais c'est ça
c'était ton truc cé un peu ton modèle
Valérie tu t'ai dit ouais j'aimerais
bien même c'était pas je dirais pas que
c'était mon modèle mais mais un petit
peu ouais parce que c'était pas le genre
d'émission qui qui faisait en fait rire
les gens c'était des c'était quand même
une émission sérieuse et à la fois qu'
faisait rire votre émission à vous si je
me rappelle bien sur Europe 1 c'est ça
et et moi j'admirais ça en fait alors
c'est qu'on pouvait faire rire on
pouvait parler des de choses sérieuses
et et et voilà j'avais envie d'être
comme toi tu vois donc ça je le dis
honnêtement Julie c'était c'était tu tu
as commencé à quel âge à avoir une
énorme passion comme ça pour les médias
j'ai commencé à l'âge de 10 ans pour
avoir uneme ouais et tu as été partout
sur tous les plateaux et cetera alors
euh attention j'ai pas été à 10 ans voir
tout non bien sûr c'est après cétait
quoi l'âge de 15 16 ans j'ai été à
partir de ouais 15 16 ans j'ai été voir
sur les PL à quel âge aujourd'hui j'ai
25 ans aujourd'hui d'accord alors euh
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que tout le monde
ne parle que de toi en ce moment et j'ai
j'aimerais savoir parce que tu on s'est
parlé tout à l'heure téléphone et
j'aimerais savoir déjà euh toi c'est le
premier animateur que tu as rencontré
Koé c'était le premier animateur oui
d'accord donc toi tuas tu avais été à la
radio le voir non j'avais pas été à la
radio j'avais gagné un concours sur
énergie pour aller à Disneyland Paris
avec avec lui et une douzaine de
participants d'accord c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est rencontré ouais donc tu vas
à Disneyland Paris bon tu dois être
comme une folle c'est un c'est un rêve
pour toi bah c'était c'était génial
c'était euh moi je veux dire je je
voulais faire de la de la radio lui son
émission c'était dingue après attention
moi c'était pas de c'était pas de
l'animation radio que je dans ce
genre-là que je voulais faire moi
c'était plus de l'information que je
voulais faire ça formation un peu
divertissement comme nous quoi on fait
aujourd'hui c'était pas c'était c'était
pas du divertissement que je voulais
faire c'était vraiment de l'information
d'accord mais bon quand même tu te dis
euh c'est quand même l'occasion me dis
c'est c'est c'est l'occasion de t'ouvrir
des portes c'est le c'est c'est le gars
qui peut me conseiller en premier parce
qu'il a fait des émissions télé parce
que j'aime son émission et ce qu'il fait
et c'est lui qui peut me me conseiller
en fait au mieux et et en fait moi j'y
vais mais je tu as quel âge à l'époque
ah bah moi à l'époque j'avais 15 ans 15
ans d'accord donc je tweet c'est tu dis
quoi tes PARENTS tu dis je pars j'ai
gagné un concours je suis comme une ben
en fait ça s'est pas passé comme ça
c'était le jour de Noël il fallait
tweeter à mort ouais il fallait tweeter
le celui qui avait le plus tweeté il
gagnait en fait un voyage avec avec coé
donc j'ai tweeté à mort le jour de Noël
je me suis complètement en fait détachée
de de de de toute ma famille et j'ai dit
moi je tweete à mort je tweete je tweete
je tweete je tweete et là bam je gagne
on me contacte on dit bah ouais en fait
tu tu tu vas remporter ce tu vas
remporter ce concours commence à à à
prévenir tes parents et cetera donc moi
je préviens mes parents je je suis comme
une dingue je dis il faut m'emmener il
faut absolument m'emmener en fait oui et
mes parents sont sont sont comme des
fous me disent bah bah ouais en fait on
va tonmener et il m'emmène et et et il
m'emmène
alors donc là tu arrives là-bas tu
rencontres toute l'équipe et là tu
rencontres coé c'est ça quand tu le
rencontre tu es comment tu es tu vois
ton ton idole c'est je dirais pas que
c'est je dirais pas que c'est un idole
je dirais que c'est j'admire son travail
j'admire ce qu'il fait tu lui dis quoi
quand tu le vois et ben je lui dis rien
que la vidéo la vidéo elle est sur
Youtube on dit rien quand on se présente
tu vois c'est ça ouis c'est il fait la
bise à tout le monde c'est filmé c'est
et ça se passe naturellement en fait il
y a pas de il y a pas de
kiproco
alors donc là est-ce que tu lis des
liens d'amitié avec Koé ensuite au cours
du séjour ou pas du tout oui j'en lis
entre guillemets je dis bien entre
guillemets un parce que c'est pas c'est
pas vérifiable et c'est
pas c'est pas encore je dirais entre
guillemets ça n'a pas été filmé alors
après je pense qu'Energie l'a filmé mais
et moi je je ne l'ai pas en ma
possession c'est quoi c'est-à-dire Queen
fait moi j'avais j'ai énormément peur
des manèges à sensation mais vraiment
très peur et euh et je ne voulais
absolument pas faire de manège à
sensation ouais et on est arrivé devant
je je ne sais pas quel manège c'était
mais c'était pas Diana Jones c'était
l'autre ouais c'est un manège
assensation et il m'a dit moi je veux
monter avec elle donc il me pointe du
doigt et je dis waouh je dis moi je je
dis en fait non je peux pas j'arrive pas
parce que c'était filmé en fait il
filmait en fait la scène ouais quand on
montait à côté de lui et je dis non moi
je peux pas je je je je balise j'ai trop
peur des manèges sensation je peux pas
et il me dit si tu vas venir avec moi et
on on va le faire ensemble bon bah dans
ces cas-là pas de problème je monte avec
toi on y va j'ai hurlé j'ai j'ai
vraiment hurlé mais c'était encore une
fois de son côté il y avait rien de
dramatique tu vois non mais là c'était
oui c'était quoi vous avez rigolé
ensemble voilà vous on a rigolé on a
parlé on a échangé en sortant du manège
il m'a dit mais tu as l'air d'être
quelqu'un de bien qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire dans la vie je lui ai expliqué je
dis moi mon rêve c'est d'être animatrice
radio je dit moi ma grand-mère qui est
d'ailleurs maintenant décédée m'a payé
tout un studio radio je veux dire c'est
d'accord donc tu étais à fond dans la
radio c'est j'étais à fond dans la radio
et et et c'est ce que je lui dis je lui
dis moi je fais des maquettes radio si
un jour tu es tu es tu veux les écouter
moi je te les fait écouter avec grand
plaisir c'est c'est c'est c'est ce qui
me passionne quoi alors justement donc
là euh le séjour euh se termine enfin tu
et là tout s'est bien passé en fait tu
es hyper contente quand tu rentres tout
tout s'est bien passé donc on a échangé
nos numéros puisque puisque en fait il
me dit à ce moment-là comme tu es là
maintenant je me vois comme moi quand
j'avais 15 ans bien sûr c'est vrai parce
que lui il a une histoire incroyable
aussi il a démarré très très tôt il a
démarré et et on et on va encore m'en
vouloir mais il y a la présomption
d'innocence et cetera et cetera et on
peut me dire ce qu'on veut c'est ce que
tu m'as dit tout à l'heure au téléphone
d'ailleurs ouais exactement et moi ça je
le prône chacun se fait son avis et il y
a aucun problème là-dessus mais il m'a
dit moi je te vois comme moi quand
j'avais 15 ans
ouais et moi là à ce moment-là je prends
je prends confiance et je prends son
numéro je prends son snap S et en fait
il y a aucun souci je me dis mais mais
c'est mais mais c'est mais mais c'est
comme une fille de 15 ans qui se dit
c'est Royal comme une fille de 15 16 ans
qui se dit c'est royal c'est magnifique
en fait alors justement alors ensuite
comment quand est-ce que tu le
revois alors je vais le je comme je le
dis à la police je vais le revoir
plusieurs fois d'accord la première fois
c'est quand premier la première fois
donc ça a été à Disneyland mais la
deuxième fois donc après Disney la
deuxième fois ça a été à à Genève alors
à Genève donc toi tu vas à Genève pour
le voir il me demande d'aller le voir à
Genève oui d'accord tu vas avec qui
avec ma sœur et mon beau frère d'accord
donc là tu y vas tu es toute contente et
c'est vrai que tu tuas fait une maquette
j'avais fait une maquette ouais j'étais
trop contente parce que je préparais ça
depuis longtemps donc tu lu je vais
venir te voir à Genève pour te faire
écouter ma maquettei je lui pas dit je
vais je vais venir te voir à Genève
c'est que j'avais fait ma maquette je lu
dit écoute je t'envoie ma maquette je
l'ai faite et puis il me dit écoute je
suis à Genève viens et et on verra ça
là-bas d'accord donc ça ces messages je
les ai ouais et et je précise bien que
je les ai
et donc moi mineur bah pas le permis je
peux pas y aller en voiture en mode je
je vais rouler sans permis donc je
décide d'appeler mes parents mes parents
horrifiés à minuit de que je les
réveille pour ça il me disent absolument
non mais je vais réveiller ma sœur je
dis écoute AUH il faut que tu m' il faut
que tu me sauves il faut qu'on il faut
qu'on y alle absolument il veut écouter
ma maquête c'est quelqu'un qui qui fait
un travail en or et et moi il va écouter
mon travail à moi et je le connais pas
personnellement tu vois à cette à cette
période là je connais son travail et
c'est là que je me dis en fait il va
reconnaître peut-être mon travail et il
va me donner des conseils et c'était
surtout ça que je voulais parce que à 15
ans tu peux pas te tu peux pas te
promettre grande animatrice radio et
cetera d'accord et ma sœur me dit bon
écoute allez c'est bon vas-y je t'emmène
je t'emmène je va je vais demander à
donc à son copain et cetera et il décide
de m'emmener donc on y va le lendemain
d'accord bon et donc là bon la TER je et
qu'est-ce qui se passe alors là-bas donc
au départ et je tiens à le
préciser je lui ai dit écoute je suis
pas sûr de venir et il me dit ah mais
toi en fait tu ne peux jamais bouger
point d'exclamation point d'exclamation
d'exclamation il y avait trois points
d'exclamation tu ne peux jamais bouger
euh de ce fait j'ai répondu que si je
pouvais bouger et que je trouverais des
solutions donc je l'ai trouvé et c'est
là qu'il m'a donné rendez-vous à à son
hôtel précis telle heure telle date
enfin bref tout ça j'y suis allée donc
avec mon beaufrère ma
sœur on a bu un verre et euh et et et à
ce moment-là à un moment donné dans
parce que mon frère il y avait mon frère
moi ma sœur
lui et à ce moment-là en fait il s'est
on a bu et cetera et il s'est dit bon
bah on va aller moi il faut que j'aille
me préparer Julie vient avec moi écouter
ma me faire écouter ta maquette on monte
dans la
chambre ton beaufrère ta ta sœur vont
aller vont aller au casino parce qu'il y
avait un casino dans l'hôteil on va
aller au casino et puis et puis on verra
après
donc moi je décide de monter avec avec
lui donc donc donc encore une fois la
présemption d'innocence est là je l'ai
fait je l'ai suivi et
euh et ma sœur était un petit peu contre
elle sentait le je sais je sais pas
pourquoi elle elle le sentait pas mais
j'y suis allée quand même et c'est à ce
momentl que que que s'est passé que ce
sont passés les
faits les fait que voilà tu dis que les
fait que tu as déjà expliqué euh voilà
les fait que j'ai déjà expliqué qui pour
moi et qui pour moi ont été ont été très
très difficiles à entendre parce que lui
je je je le comprends et pour sa
compagne aussi je le comprends que ça ce
soit très difficile et je leurai dit
encore je leurais dit encore aujourd'hui
il y a la présemption d'innocence et
chacun se fait son avis propre et
personnel mais moi à à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui j'ai je suis
complètement anéantie par tout ça j'ai
perdu beaucoup mais c'était c'était
c'était il y a 10 ans cette affaire
c'était il y a 10 ans ouais et tu l'as
revu après je l'ai revu ouais combi
combien combien de jours combien de
semaines après tu l'as revu plusieurs
fois ou je l'ai revu plusieurs fois que
tu allais encore à ces émissions tu
allais encore dans le public j'allais
encore à ces émissions j'allais encore
au public mais d'ailleurs j'étais venu
vous voir avec j'ai d'ailleurs des
photos mais mais en fait j'allais faire
plein d'émissions radio moi j'étais
j'étais passionné de ça mais mais après
ça parce qu'il je te dis t les gens se
posent la question se disent pourquoi tu
as continué à aller dans le public
pourquoi tu as continué à le voir je me
suis persuadé que ce qui était arrivé en
fait ce n'était pas ce n'était pas réel
ce qui était arrivé c'était pas
dramatique parce que ça a duré peut-être
je dirais une minute avant que les
appels de ma sœur
retentissent des dizaines de fois et je
me suis dit ça tout ça c'est pas réel
tout ça c'est pas réel